c'est une sortie mondiale et
théâtralisée celle du nouvel album de
michael jackson après cinq ans d'absence
discographique ternie par un revers de
gloire le chanteur star revient avec un
disque baptisé invicible mail est il
vraiment encore invincible
olivier les news à claude classement il
a baptisé son dernier album invincible
il présente est indestructible la diva
de la pop est pourtant un homme affaibli
image quelque peu pathétique d'un
artiste au tournant de sa carrière
le jour j pour mj sortie mondiale de son
nouveau disque
un événement la presse serait pas en
neuf ans que michael jackson n'a pas
sorti de nouvelles chansons inédites
les rumeurs les plus folles courent la
fabrication de cet album aurait coûté
entre 15 et 30 millions de dollars
invraisemblable sonne le bambi du rock a
travaillé quatre années avec les plus
grands producteurs du moment les plus
grandes banques les plus chères
une cinquantaine de titres qui ont été
enregistrées comme vous avez pu voir sur
l'album 50 titres sur l'album
donc je pense qu'ils sont arrivés au
stade final de production c'était très
cher
michael jackson l'homme de tous les
records 125 millions d'albums vendus en
trente années de carrière dont 47
millions d'exemplaires de thriller une
poule aux oeufs d'or pour une maison de
disques ou cette affaire successivement
il a jamais vendu moins de 20 millions 4
d'albums en france donc je pense que sa
bonne objectifs fixés mille quatre cent
mille millions 5
et la musique dans tous hélas pêche
chanson 77 minutes de rythme de sons
on peut plus aujourd'hui attendre de
jackson une prise de risque jackson il a
tout à perdre et donc il définit
littéralement le milieu ce qu'on appelle
aux états unis le middle of the road est
lassé jackson aujourd'hui c'est un drame
parce qu'il a été
peter pan il a été celui par qui en
avait l'action l'inventivité la
créativité
michael jackson des plus innovateurs
justin roy qui défend son royaume lui
dans la fortune la popularité et le
visage se désagrège